Thor gets a little bit of a haircut dogs
get a haircut how does that how does
that come about like I mean you know get
the makeover gone I don't want to wear
the wigs to put on kind of just run with
it creative license Fair on set there's
a lot of flying wires for Chris plenty
of fight moves one just as strong
look-alike stunt double and thousands of
Australian fans waiting for the chance
to meet the god of thunder yeah but Tom
and I spent a lot of time sort of you
know in between tights coming out and
trying to sign autographs and take
photos like hundreds hundreds of selfies
yeah very good are the one-handed say I
might kind of a few steps ahead of me
kind of getting the cameras ready and
handing him to me four months of
shooting took place all over Australia
from the Gold Coast to 36 giant sound
stages in Queensland come on this is
amazing right this is the set of a scart
the whole thing is the size of an
American football field to 450
construction workers four months to
build this amazing set
[Music]
welcome to ice guard now this is the
chair that in prisons Thor
oh yeah now the multiple four hammers
onset but there is only one hero hammer
this is it and it's got some good weight
to it I guess about twenty to
twenty-five pounds
we know each other he's a friend from
work
but this epic battle between Thor and
Hulk is what Chris was looking forward
to the most before we didn't written
them the script it was like we want to
sort of center it around this and that's
I mean you know I was like oh what else
can you throw in and what can we do that
we haven't done before and it's almost
like your own version of civil war show
here in space yeah I'm gonna go hit the
gym right now and I'll be in there like
lifting these little egg dinky weights
to like everybody a couple you asked me
to break down this door Ragnarok
behind-the-scenes special and there were
a lot of questions about Firelord serger
and things that we saw in the last
trailer so I wanted to do a video
addressing that stuff so there is a new
round of that Thor ticket giveaway -
it's for to IMAX gift certificates all
you have to do to enter is just be a
subscriber leave a comment on this video
announce a new winner at the end of this
the interesting thing in the behind the
scenes you may remember some of the
images that they used from earlier this
year when they were actually filming and
they were posting on Instagram like you
see him in his plain clothes here with
the long hair that's when he's on earth
getting ready to talk to doctor strange
like this is the same outfit he's
wearing in that Doctor Strange
post-credit seed tea I don't drink tea
what do you drink no tea but you've all
seen the other trailers so you know that
his hammer gets destroyed and we see him
on the Rainbow Bridge later in the movie
when he's full of whatever Odin force or
the power of the hammer or an infinity
gem but the funny thing here is that
when he's on this blue screen set it
looks like he's calling the hammer to
himself and he has short hair so it just
doesn't make a lot of sense because when
we see him at the beginning of that
infinity war trailer and he face plants
on the Milano like and everybody freaks
out he doesn't have the hammer with him
so it sounds like he ends the movie
without the hammer but we've all seen
the concept footage from infinity war
where they just sort of crop out the
weapons that he's using so it makes it
look like he might be using a version of
ultimate Thor's hammer
Ragnarok is the process of him becoming
ultimate Thor from the comics just like
the biggest baddest version of Thor that
you've ever seen
in order to take down hella but that's
still in theory territory
most of these blue-screen sets where you
see him jumping up really high doing the
hammer strikes that's actually from
really early in the movie and we
actually got a time line now for Serdar
so this is all overlapping with Captain
America Civil War stuff it just kind of
explains what he was doing while that
was happening he was on a quest across
the nine realms to try and learn about
the things that he saw at his vision the
infinity gems and that just happens to
take him to Fire Lord Surtur's planet so
obviously you've seen the World Tree you
know it exists down here right next to
Hellas planet where she resides but the
cool thing is remember the original Thor
movie how he's talking to Jane Foster
about how things that seemed magic are
really just science that you haven't
explained yet we learned a little bit
about where Serdar lives in the MCU his
planet is actually a Dyson Sphere that's
built around a star so like what you're
seeing here is the inside of the Dyson
Sphere all these weird smaller fire
demons and they reveal that there's a
giant dragon ii don't know if Thor's
actually gonna fight that in the movie
because there are a lot of toys and a
lot of the Disneyland rides stuff that
you don't see a whole lot of in the
movies they do that with the guardians
of the galaxy so just keep your eyes
peeled for surgery riding a giant dragon
somewhere in the movie and I don't know
if he's gonna be the stand-in for the
Midgard serpent because Midgard serpent
is a big part of Ragnarok and a big part
of the Thor mythos and if they're gonna
be doing big crazy surgery things that
it would make sense they try to include
him but this might just be the stand-in
for that you're probably at least a
little bit familiar with them from the
comics he's this green cosmic being so
there was this big question about how
they would tackle him in the MCU and you
see a couple different versions of him
in the trailer there's like the giant
version that Hulk is getting ready to
punch like look how small Hulk is
compared to Surtur then you see him
fighting Thor with his sword Twilight
earlier in the trailer and he doesn't
seem nearly as big so just to explain
that he can change his size at will so
it sounds like early in the movie Thor
just winds up there trying to learn more
about the infinity gems he barely gets
away eventually makes his way to earth
then you have the encounter with hella
you have the planet Hulk
elements of the movie then later after
things go full ragnarok he's unleashed
in his full glory on Asgard and that's
where you see Hulk going up against him
you're gonna see Hulk bite a whole lot
of big creatures they're hyping up the
Fenris wolf fight here but really I
think the big one is gonna be Surtur and
while I do think that Hulk can defeat
Surtur like they're just gonna show you
how badass Hulk can get I don't think
he'll be able to kill him not a lot of
people die in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe they just changed form or they
go away for a while
even Red Skull is still floating
somewhere out in the universe wherever
the tesseract sent him but the rest of
the behind the scenes is pretty straight
up you just see a couple of the Asgard
shots this shot where he's wielding
Odin's spear looks like it's from later
on the trailer from these scenes here
and then this looks like it also happens
much earlier in the movie where he walks
up and puts the hammer on Loki's lap
again this is just a nice callback to
the first Thor movie where he set it on
his chest still not worthy still can't
lift it if you want to keep Loki from
moving around they just put the hammer
on top of them you'd think he'd be able
to teleport himself away because he does
have magic in the way that Doctor
Strange has magic but maybe something
about the Hammers magic cancels that out
but that's like a whole other thing we
haven't talked a lot about Doctor
Strange in the movie mostly because I
think they want to maintain the surprise
and because he's not that big of a thing
like think about how much Iron Man wound
up being in spider-man homecoming it
wasn't nearly as much as they marketed
so I think that's why they're spending
most of their time hyping up the Thor
Hulk fight even though that itself isn't
the biggest part of the movie it's just
a really easy thing to sell to little
kids like oh I can't wait to see hope
spite Thor even though that's probably
only gonna be five minutes of the film
well let me know what you guys think
about all this I think generally people
say that they're more hyped up about
Thor Ragnarok than anything else
I'm not surprised it's gonna be pretty
crazy so the really cool thing is they
also drop some new infinity war there's
some vision stuff that I want to talk
about so I'll post a video for that
later tonight it has to do with the
Infinity Gauntlet and Thanos assembling
all the gems congratulations to Daniel
sand of all your the latest giveaway
winner please private message me on the
back end of my channel so I can get your
contact details so infinity war should
post really soon you can click here to
rewatch that last big thor trailer and
you can click here for brand new Rick
morty thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome i'll see you guys
tonight